a narwhal's horn is actually an enlarged
tooth and not a horn at all
today we're talking about narwhals
unicorns of the sea
nice shirt
thanks
my grandfather jacques cousteau studied
and explored the earth's ocean i do too
and our submarine is in arctic waters
searching for the narwhal
oh
he's a beauty
narwhals can grow up to 17 feet in
length and their front tooth can grow up
to 10 feet in length it's the only
straight tusk in the world
typically these are only found on males
and are actually full of up to 10
million nerve endings helping the
narwhal detect pressure salt levels and
even temperature in the water
here's an interesting fact a narwhal
tusk is flexible it can bend about one
foot in any direction without breaking
it was originally thought that these
tusks were for dueling but a new theory
suggests they're for attracting a mate
narwhals don't migrate like other whale
species
they spend their entire lives in icy
arctic waters hunting squid
fish
and crab
if you want to see one live you'll have
to come up north because narwhals don't
thrive in captivity
rather they die
some animals we humans just can't tame
i've dedicated my life to studying the
ocean
but sometimes you come across something
so marvelous you have to wonder
what the heck is going on down here
today we're talking about the mimic
octopus
octopus
octopuses are rather curious creatures
when exposed they're vulnerable to
predators so typically they like to stay
hidden and when they do move they do so
by walking along the ocean's floor on
their eight legs
but in 1998 scientists discovered an
octopus residing in the shallow waters
of indonesia doing something quite
strange
over the course of two years they filmed
it and nine other similar octopuses
mimicking behaviors of at least three
different species
they found it swimming its legs
outstretched high above the ocean floor
like a lionfish
flattened out gliding over the bottom
like a flatfish and extending its
tentacles to mimic a poisonous sea snake
this allows the mimic octopus to hide in
plain sight
astonishing
camouflage is important in the oceans
it's a cutthroat world outside these
submarine walls
today we're talking about sea horses and
their ability to camouflage
my grandfather jacques cousteau always
stood out in a crowd because of his
style
these seahorses do just the opposite
seahorses are masters of camouflage
the pygmy seahorse is one of the most
well camouflaged species in the ocean
and the smallest variety of seahorses
that exist
they're the size of a paperclip
in fact the pygmy seahorse wasn't
discovered until someone was examining a
piece of coral it was on
seahorses much like chameleons can
change color they change color to
confuse predators as well as to convey
emotions to one another especially
during courtship
the speed at which they change color
depends on what's happening as a
response to fear it's rapid whereas if
it's due to hormonal changes it's much
slower
it's gone
what do you mean it's gone
no no it's right there
stealthy seahorse
humans can experience over 10 million
colors it's rather amazing
but not to the mantis shrimp
beautiful isn't it
this is a mantis shrimp manta shrimp
have 16 color receptors in their eyes
the most of any animal on our planet
what does this mean
now think about the world you live in
you're experiencing all this with three
optical receptors
because the manta shrimp has so many
more than us their light detecting
ability is astronomically better
and this can help them spot prey quicker
making it an extraordinary
hunter it's only about four inches long
but can strike with a force of 335
pounds
well
it takes nine pounds to break a nose 25
to break a small bone and 400 to break
through a block of cement the movement
of the mantis shrimp claw is one of the
fastest for any animal on earth
they've even been known to break through
aquarium tanks
remarkable
today we're exploring the deep ocean and
it's rarely seen creatures
my grandfather jacques cousteau was
always looking to chronicle the wonders
of the ocean and the giant isopod is one
of the most fascinating and strange
looking
these crustaceans live thousands of feet
beneath the ocean surface typically
between 500 and 7000 feet deep they can
grow up to two feet long
but this one's just a baby
the reason they're so big is due to
something sorry
it's due to something called sea
gigantism
we don't know why this happens it might
be due to deep ocean pressure or to
scarcity of food resources either way
these guys are huge
they're carnivores and they have four
sets of jaws but can go for years
without eating
are you guys eating
you barely lasted an hour
one isopod in captivity in japan
survived five years without eating
okay give me
hold on i need a minute the ocean is
particularly captivating today
all right what's on the docket
nudibranchs
ah yes of course nudibranchs i love
these
nudibranchs are small
about the size of my fingertip
these are particularly amazing animals
and you can find them all over the world
if you look hard enough
on top these things that look like ears
are chemosensory organs
they help them see because nudibranchs
are pretty much blind they can only
sense light and dark
their bright colors aren't for one
another obviously they're to alert
predators that they're poisonous
but generally speaking oh they're just
adorable let's look at some
roll the tape
nudibranchs are hermaphroditic but
cannot mate alone so when these guys
aren't looking for food they're looking
for sex
not too bad a
life nudibranchs sex crazed poisonous
sea slugs
can we put that on a t-shirt
perfect
submarine's a bit chilly today team hats
on
it's important to have a good support
system at sea my grandfather jacques
cousteau knew how valuable friends were
beautiful specimens aren't they i've got
a pistol shrimp and gobi fish in this
bag these two are in a mutualistic
symbiotic relationship which means they
depend on each other for survival
here's how it works
the pistol shrimp is an amazing digger
but nearly blind
the gobi fish likes living in ocean
floor tunnels but can't dig the gobi has
great eyesight the shrimp has a great
digging claw
they're a perfect match
these two pair up and as the shrimp digs
the gobi keeps watch for predators
once they pair they're inseparable and
that's the deal
the gobi gets a home and the shrimp gets
a seeing eye fish
scientists aren't sure how these two
find each other in the first place it
could be a chemical or an optical
attraction
either way
it's a beautiful thing
look at it out there it looks calm
doesn't it
it's actually swarming with microscopic
life
it's like my grandfather jean cousteau
used to say
everyone always talks about fish and
whales
let's talk about phytoplankton
they're small
it's estimated that in every teaspoon of
seawater there's about a hundred
thousand of them
but you need a microscope to see them
they're the unsung heroes of our ocean
more than half the oxygen in our
atmosphere is thanks to phytoplankton
and today we'll learn about two types
let's talk about coca-lithophores every
day in the ocean they're battling
viruses and bacteria and each time they
die they release a little puff of oxygen
into the atmosphere
if you were to look down from space you
could see this immense battlefield full
of trillions of their dead
ever heard of the white cliffs of dover
made up of dead coccolithophore
skeletons romantic isn't it
and now
dinoflagellates
these are responsible for bioluminescent
waters or glowing oceans
they're also responsible for blood red
tides
when dinoflagellates bloom they turn the
water a deep crimson red
these red tides are dangerous and
responsible for loss of ocean and
possibly human life
phytoplankton giveth
and take us in return
you